et puis québec lance ses consultations
prébudgétaires le ministre des finances
eric girard a dévoilé les thèmes de ces
consultations qui se font en ligne on
parle de réduction de l'écart de
richesse avec l'ontario réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
inflation rareté main d'oeuvre
renforcement du réseau de la santé
hausse du financement d'éducation les
conditions de vie des aînés et l'
équilibre budgétaire le ministre a
participé aujourd'hui au lancement de
l'édition 2022 du bilan de la fiscalité
au québec de la chaire de recherche en
fiscalité et en finances publiques sont
titulaires luc godbout est avec nous ce
soir le peu de bouillon soir bonsoir
d'abord peut-être peut-être un
commentaire luxure l'annnonce du
ministre boulet au sujet de la hausse du
salaire minimum 14 25 maintenant 15 $ en
2023 ckoi de la logique
d'abord je râle ça viendra le 15 $ il
s'en viennent nous leurrons pour 2023 la
logique c'est de maintenir le lecointe
sommes entre le salaire moyen le et le
salaire minimum à 50 % et ils se sont
engagés la fin des libéraux et depuis
que le gouvernement de la coalition
avenir québec sont là se sont engagés à
faire ça et donc si le salaire moyen
augmente le salaire minimum suisse et
comme il est à la remorque et donc nous
aurons un 14 et 25 cette année
probablement 1 15 $ en 2000 23 mai 2023
ouais mais au delà du salaire minimum ce
qui est important c'est ce qui reste
dans la poche des ménages et une fois
qu'on a payé nos impôts nos cotisations
sociales est pris en compte les
prestations gouvernementales
si on reste plus dans nos poches et si
ça nous éloigne plus de la pauvreté jeu
au québec à 14 25 15 $ en ontario bah
tant mieux c'est pas le 15 $ qui est
important c'est de s'éloigner d'un seuil
de faible revenu et ça déjà l'année
passée en 2021 avant la hausse nous
étions pour en première position
canadienne que nous soyons un c'est une
personne seule un couple avec un enfant
un couple sans enfant ou familles
monoparentales et ça ça va se maintenir
en 2022 à l'opposé avec le bilan fiscal
que vous faites à chaque année vous
compilé les données fiscales québec
canada municipalité notamment oui mais
dans le fond pour le bo bo pour
commencer pour avancer toutes les
recettes fiscales qui sont perçus sur le
territoire québécois peu importe l'ordre
de gouvernement alors quand on prend le
gouvernement canadien le gouvernement du
québec les municipalités le régime des
rentes on arrive dans un total de 174
milliards pour l'année 2020 il sommes et
ça nous permet par la suite en se
trouvant des indicateurs de se comparer
dans le temps de se comparer avec
d'autres avec un indicateur par exemple
en divisant soit par le pib ça nous
permet de faire différentes comparaisons
alors 174 175 milliards de dollars de
recettes fiscales au total au québec
quand on regarde par exemple par rapport
à la coved 19 lakovic 19 quand même
coûter des sous l'impact de la pandémie
sur les revenus de l'état habituellement
quand on est en récession
les recettes fiscales diminuent en au
même rythme que le pib nominal cette
fois ci le pib nominal a réduit de 2 4%
et les recettes fiscales ont diminué de
-2 1% là qu'il faut il faut comprendre
pourquoi mais je vais vous le rappeler
cette espèce elle a su comprendre à
l'impôt sur le revenu la pcu la pcr
heures salle a donné des milliards aux
contribuables
mais ces sommes-là est imposable donc la
cie ont produit leur déclaration d'impôt
sur le revenu à ottawa et à québec ils
ont payé plus d'impôts si bien que la
mode d'imposition impôt sur le revenu
aux crues en 2020 malgré la pandémie un
autre source des positions qui est ultra
cyclique habituellement c'est le profit
des compagnies quand ça va mal en
récession les compagnies des profits
disparaissent et paye plus d'impôt sur
les profits et l'homme malgré l'énorme
pandémique on a eu les recettes sur le
profit des compagnies au crû de 1%
encore une fois si on se rappelle la
subvention salariale d'urgence du canada
si on paye 75 % des salaires des
compagnies ça a aidé à rester rentable
et ils ont continué de payer de l'impôt
sur les profits par contre garder des
taxes à la consommation on voit c'est
bien les taxes ont diminué ou encore une
consommation sont se rappelle l'apport
débit les restaurants sont fermés on
prend l'argent qu'on voulait moment
consommer en restaurant on s'en va
d'épicerie on achète la farine ont fait
du pays des tartelettes qui sont des
produits non taxables wet est donc
évidemment il y a un transfert de
consommation des produits taxables et
non taxable et les recettes fiscales des
taxes ont diminué quand on regarde
l'ensemble de ce qu'on appelle le poids
de la fiscalité au québec en 2020 et
qu'on compare le québec à l'ensemble des
pays de l'osce et des espaces et l' ocde
votre comparables notre comparable cdp
blot séduit mais on ne choisit de
prendre les pays dont le fmi dit que
c'était des pays avancés ok donc
lorsqu'on on a ça c'est toujours notre
174 milliards qu'on divise par le pib le
québec arrive en 9e position
donc c'est sa droite du graphique on
voit vraiment les lits nation où il ya
un poids de fiscalité plus élevée
danemark france belgique notamment tout
à fait pile québec est comparable à la
norvège avec un autre en avril 2,8 pour
ça alors que dans les pays avancés le
canada se retrouve sous la moyenne de
l'os et des oeufs des pays avancés donc
on peut constater comme ça notre
comparaison et si on prend pour
l'ensemble des pays de l'osce et de on
n'a jamais été en neuvième pour le plus
beau plus haut en tout cas le banc ne
vient plus beau que la neuvième position
est la neuvième position ne jamais eu
dans les vingt dernières années donc on
est en augmentation un peu de la
tendance du poids de la fiscalité est en
augmentation québec depuis 20 ans depuis
depuis 20 ans depuis dix ans se poile a
augmenté dans le bilan de la fiscalité
ouais tout à fait le poids le poids mais
mais le poids de la fiscalité dans les
10 provinces canadiennes sans exception
a augmenté si on prend le québec il
augmenté de 2 points de pourcentage en
10 ans on est passé de 36 8% du pib en
poids de la fiscalité à 38,8 c'est moins
que la moyenne canadienne soit dit en
passant les provinces pétrolières vont
augmenter plus que nous bien qu'ils ont
un fardeau plus faibles donc les cancers
à petit ils sont ni regarde
spécifiquement au québec quel
gouvernement a causé la hausse du poids
de la fiscalité c'est principalement
gouvernement du québec depuis 10 ans
avec la moitié de la hausse qui vient de
lui les municipalités ont pratiquement
pas changé leur point nommé ont diminué
un petit peu plus leurs airs cubains il
faut se rappeler que ben de 2010 à 2017
2012 à 2017 il y avait une augmentation
du taux pour améliorer le financement
est depuis 2000 18 ans bonifier le
régime pour donner des meilleures
prestations donc ça l'amène à une
augmentation des cotisations au régime
des rentes du québec très clair très
intéressant le godbout merci beaucoup
merci au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit